les clivages politiques les français
sont pour qu on les déplace en
permanence 2,6 après c'est intéressant
ce que vous dites justement sur sur la
droite économiquement c'est là n'est pas
la question puisque les différences
entre macro et la droite je pense même
que macron a été plus loin que la droite
ne l'a jamais fait je réalise il va se
reposer ça va plutôt être sur des
questions sociétales potentiellement sur
les gestes que fera mme accro à sa
gauche pour conseillé de conserver une
partie de son électorat qui est déjà
parti pour la plupart les sympathisants
de gauche qui ont voté macron ce que
commencent à se demander pour être
vraiment dans ce cas votre avis bahia on
parle beaucoup des pays-bas évidemment
voilà création médicalement assistée
pour des rythmes en parler coupé de la
tentation de yutz assembler sa
rattrapage une chose c'est plutôt
symbolique qu'autre chose
donc là il ya peu de chance quand même
que la droite s'opposent par principe ou
face de ce combat syntaxe et les yachts
en date exactement mais mais c'est
vraiment l'avenir qui me dira comment
les constructive vont pouvoir se
comporter dans notre situation c'est là
où je